boa tarde boa tarde a todos
é realmente um prazer voltar a casa já
que isto vai e não contava entretanto
foi convidado para voltar pra isso tanto
para visitar a instituição talvez mas
também para criar uma testemunha
principalmente através do olhar não
e por que por uma razão muito simples é
que eu sou dado a conferência
normalmente relacionadas com negócios e
investimentos a tendência celular tanta
coisa mas relacionado com a conquest
moto e um táxi mas o contraste anos a
fazer em termos profissionais a passar a
sua experiência enquanto ganha além do
dinheiro que consegue extrair da
imprensa oficial do país
e essa é a razão pela qual é o de todos
os temas deixei os crachás duas taças de
tudo a porta e se lhe trazer os mesmos
só parte do investimento naquilo que eu
acho que a coisa mais importante da vida
e que morreu também muito daquilo que eu
tenho são as pessoas
as pessoas principalmente aquelas com as
quais o trabalho com os quais o brinco
os quais me divirto tocar muitas
felizmente e porque a vida como o
investimento naquilo que a partir de
território ou seja não gosto muito de
poder
invista nos meses de outono que eu tenho
deus é para concretizar os meus
objectivos apresentação
a agência já cedeu a mafalda que que ao
invés de ensinar sempre me inspirou de
toda a gente está a china criou a marca
dela um sem-fim de pessoas que eu tenho
e fazer valer o que estou fazendo aqui
hoje
[Música]
quero contar nos alcançar contar uma
história
avançar
depois todos o tema
sou eu
bom aconteceu e se chamará apresentação
o calcanhar midas e não de quilos e
vocês vão perceber porque depois a esta
fusão
esta mescla canalha do carinho que eu
tentei fazer o que acho que vai resultar
se não receberem
quem não está não está ok
temos um problema
não há problema
temos a solução eu falo que vou tentar
fazer com essa representação que é mais
fácil estava um pouco nervosa sinto o
meu primeiro livro era nada mais nada
menos do que uma fotografia ambiental é
e eu sair é essa reação também alguém
sabe dizer qual é o som do mar e ao
sonho não é que o que ela fez
é um sonho
cantar e por acaso é sempre vai no
melhor dos sentidos cobre a lhe
perguntar eu poder falar eu fui falar
com ela e nos amigos
não vou contar o contexto é uma festa e
se lhe pergunta qual é o sonho final por
trás do estudo e ela contou que o sonho
dela era é só lançar um cd do estudo é
que não foi a resposta dela mas ela seu
entender e conseguiu realizar o sonho
dela tentou pagar as contas
a opinião das pessoas que criticavam
normal mas mesmo só dinheiro ou cartão
e é assim que trabalhar na vida não
tenha sofrido com as mesmas razões aos
meus amigos que singraram ou estão a
começar agora é a singrar tenham sofrido
mas a esta provação início muitas vezes
matam um sonho que eu acho que é o mais
gratificante conclui o sonho dela
não vou falar não pressionar as músicas
não vou pra ir para a tensões não é
vender sonhos é falar sobre o uso e ela
conseguiu evitar o cd que cria a segunda
imagem
também vou ser muito honesto eu não
percebo nada da arte cultura e coisas
deste ano
nunca vi tantos entendidos em portugal
querem comentar aqui o informaram me
descobri uma coisa muito interessante
que não se tem notícia é que não é bom
nunca foi um motor foi lançado ao mar
que era fantástico
um homem é o circuito mais ou menos
controlado contactos privilegiados e
facilidade de chegar
e propôs dentro do sonho de qualquer um
homem tentar que um passo de um processo
de trabalho deus quer só nem o mundo eu
acho que ninguém tinha noção do quão
longe a correria e fez a proposta e e
foi aceite foi o que se viu na altura
julgaram uma forma do primeiro na minha
opinião porque eu tinha só demorado 15
horas
somadas às 15 horas
reflexão tudo leva tempo
na altura já tinha feito o trabalho
mas como eu não entendo nada da prova e
gostei do resultado
outra pessoa que concordou com isso foi
o próprio aeroporto que está aí
essa visão porque também eu também não
ser o melhor do mundo para mim perceber
que há tanta coisa boa que pode brotar
na cabeça das pessoas
não deixe que isso aconteça
eu tenho pena que o meu que a
apresentação não esteja o superlativo se
mostraram os platts só tem três lados
eram era um só que na minha opinião
acaba muito por ser a confirmação do tal
calcanhar midas o calcanhar de aquiles é
considerado uma onde quer uma fraqueza
algo não bom alguma coisa que tira
competitividade e o toque de midas com
alguém que tope e transforma em um dos
dois porque acho que essa mescla volta
nesta nesta brilha é ouro
as pessoas que a partir de então não
fazem como nós vemos os outros fazerem a
partida nós fomos preparados para tudo o
mais que um diploma uma medalha qualquer
coisa do gênero leva a promoção social
uma coisa da outra não é mesmo e três ao
valor das coisas que nós temos em casa
sem falsas modéstias mas mesmo muito
pequeno porque final do ano nós fazemos
milhões nos negócios nós fazemos nós não
quanto empresa mesmo com o trabalho que
nós vemos são o que eu quero dizer que
eu falava é normal que é mais caro do
mundo
não é que tenha um preço muito alto
preço pago por leão e não é que tudo
tenha que pagar a partida mas cada vez
que ocorre sem correr risco de vida que
é ser transparente em quatro passos 4
passa quem comprou comprou
e essa confirmação do ouro e da empresa
em 18 anos no mercado
não tem maneira de ser admitido às
empresas a oportunidade de uma visão
diferente seguinte já direcionar
esforços que o fazem direcionado ao
mercado de trabalho são capacitados por
quem vive no mundo usam um estudo e foi
assim com muito trabalho e nem todos
estamos preparados e capacitados para
isso mas é possível que a longo prazo o
valor dela mas não tem valor eu fico
muito triste
muitos amigos meus estavam numa mesa do
café são os primeiros a condenar alguém
os outros 29
vai ser um cara leal e dodô opinião dos
outros
luiz carlos vida inteira um ponto é se
não conseguir dizer bem de alguém num
dia normal usar
[Aplausos]